Throughout the course we've been
mentioning how crucial it is for
startups to keep iterating and learning.
>> In this lesson we're going to
explore how to choose the right
metrics to measure your marketing goals,
and how to track them.
Each case will be different, but
there are a few things you can consider
when choosing the metrics to follow.
You're going to learn
how to validate and
optimize your marketing efforts
through experimentation.
We'll talk about how to run
marketing experiments and
iterate based on
the results you receive.
>> And finally, on top of analyzing the
what, we will research also the why and
learn how to run experiment
with read users using your app.